j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu froid
lorsque je suis arrivé au déjeuner mais
progressivement on y arrive
d'abord vous avez eu un invité surprise
alain juppé que vous pouvez applaudir et
merci à lui d'avoir contribué à ce geste
d'unité pour les républicains et dieu
sait que nous en avons besoin
il ya eu ensuite le discours vibrant de
geoffrey que vous pouvez carrément
ovationné lui parce que vraiment je le
suis dans la campagne régionale ile de
france autour de valérie pécresse ça
fait du bien d'avoir des jeunes qui se
battent qui se mobilisent et qui
maintenant plus bénéficie d'une
légitimité démocratique puisqu'il est
avec marine le nouveau responsable des
jeunes républicains et j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour rendre en hommage à tous
ces jeunes qui ont contribué à
l'organisation à la mobilisation de
cette journée ils sont derrière vous ils
sont debout parce qu'ils ont voulu aussi
vous étiez assis et bien vous pouvez les
ovationner les remercier parce que sans
eux nous ne serions rien alors je vais
demander une fois n'est pas coutume aux
journalistes de se bouger un peu les
oreilles parce que je voudrais vous
parler à vous mes amis militants et je
voudrais vous dire que j'ai été quelque
peu surpris par la manière dont les
journées de la semaine dernière à la
baule ont été résumées par la presse en
allumant la télévision en écoutant la
radio
on nous expliquait que l'unité des
républicains avait duré huit minutes top
chrono
comme s'il était impossible de faire une
photo de famille au sein de notre
famille politique mais bien sûr qu'il ya
des ambitions bien sûr qu'il ya des
sensibilités
bien sûr qu'il ya des priorités mais
quel est aujourd'hui le parti politique
où l'on peut travailler ensemble parce
que ce que les journalistes ne savent
pas où
font semblant sans doute de ne pas
savoir c'est qu'une fois les micros
éteints une fois les caméras fermé nous
nous retrouvons tous les quinze jours en
bureau politique où il ya nicolas
sarkozy où il ya alain juppé ou il ya
françois fillon hooligans attali ou ya
xavier où il ya bruno et nous
travaillons ensemble
alors bien sûr on ne s'intéresse qu'à ce
qui ne va pas mais quel est le parti
politique aujourd'hui où l'on peut tous
travailler ensemble
et bien c'est le nôtre parce que
regarder regardez ce qui se passe au
sein du parti socialiste pensez vous un
instant aujourd'hui que monsieur macro
et monsieur montebourg puis se retrouver
ne serait ce que dans la même pièce pour
y travailler pendant quelques minutes
pensez-vous aujourd'hui concevable qu au
sein des écologistes
madame duflot et monsieur placé puissent
se retrouver et travailler ensemble
pensez vous il n'imagine imaginables un
instant que le vice-président du front
national monsieur philippot et son
président d'honneur jean marie le pen
puissent eux aussi travailler un seul
instant une même pièce
alors qu'ils ne se parlent en réalité
que par avocats interposés
donc je vais vous la dire la vérité
celle qu'on ne vous a pas encore raconté
c'est que alors que les autres familles
politiques se pulvériser s'atomise nous
au boss on travaille et on se mobilise
alors évidemment être autour d'une même
table ne suffit pas et le rassemblement
n'est pas un programme en soi le
rassemblement est parfois même
d'ailleurs cette posture que françois
hollande que les socialistes
et quand même d'ailleurs trop souvent de
responsables politiques quelle que soit
leur sensibilité utilise comme un
paravent pour cacher la vacuité de leur
propre idée le rassemblement c'est le
résultat
c'est le résultat d'une action
réformatrice c'est le résultat d'un
courage dont nous avons besoin plus que
jamais parce que les français qu'est ce
qu'ils nous disent aujourd'hui les
français
il ne cherche pas à se mettre autour
d'une table les français ils veulent la
renverser la table et ils veulent la
renverser parce qu'ils sont en colère
parce que nous sommes tous en colère et
je les comprends cette colère elle est
bien légitime parce que nous avons tous
les jours un président de la république
qui m'ont à nos concitoyens il nous ment
parce qu'ils nous avaient expliqué en
2012 souvenez-vous il suffira de se
débarrasser de nicolas sarkozy et vous
verrez il n'y aura plus de crise
économique
et qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui la
crise économique
la crise politique la crise morale et la
crise identitaire
et puis il nous ment parce qu'il nous
avait dit vous irez vous savez on ira
piocher chez les ennemis de la finance
souvenez-vous de ce discours du bourget
les ennemis de la finance et puis on ira
prendre chez les riches on ira donner
aux pauvres
mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait une fois
ayant reçu mandat du peuple
il est allé refiscalisation
supplémentaires
qui est ce qui fait des heures
supplémentaires mes amis c'est vous
ce sont ces 9 à 10 millions de nos
concitoyens qui ont parfois du mal à
joindre les deux bouts qui ont besoin de
plus de pouvoir d'achat et qui ont gagné
jusqu'à 150 euros par mois
mais est ce que françois hollande c'est
ce que 150 euros par mois ce sont 1 à
deux caddies de supermarché
ce n'est pas liliane bettencourt ce
n'est pas pierre bergé qui font des
heures supplémentaires
ceux qui font des heures supplémentaires
cesser cette classe moyenne qui a besoin
de plus d'argent qui a besoin de plus de
pouvoir d'achat et que françois hollande
a plombé par des discours où il a trahi
j'ose le mot trahi le peuple
alors cette colère bien légitime
elle exige de nous de nouvelles
attitudes de nouveaux comportements de
nouveaux logiciels et je vous le dis si
nous voulons gagner les coeurs en 2017
si nous voulons gagner les régionales
à la fin de cette année il faudra être
beaucoup plus courageux courageux
d'ailleurs dans la communication
nous parions des journalistes ya
quelques instants parce que j'incite
tous ceux qui ont la chance de pouvoir
relayer leurs convictions dans les
médias d'être beaucoup plus offensif de
ne jamais se laisser faire
ne jamais se laisser impressionner par
cette gauche bien pensante qui est là
uniquement pour le dicter sa pensée
unique beaucoup plus courageux aussi
beaucoup plus pour un jeu aussi dans nos
comportements et je tiens à saluer
aujourd'hui l'engagement et la promesse
qu'a faite
valérie pécresse la candidate que je
soutient ardemment en ile de france
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit valérie pécresse
elle a dit vous savez les candidatures à
tous et les candidatures pour la vie
c'est fini
moi je suis pour le non cumul des
mandats je suis pour le non cumul des
mandats
non seulement simultanées mais le non
cumul dans le temps parce que nous avons
changé d'époque et parce qu'il faut
imposer un nouveau logiciel et créer de
l'oxygène et il faudrait être plus
courageux pas seulement dans la
communication
pas seulement dans les comportements il
faudra être beaucoup plus courageux dans
l'action
parce que le courage c'est certes dire
le courage c'est certes faire mais le
courage c'est surtout tenir et j'incite
le prochain président de la république
j'ai un souhait que je ne cache pas
c'est que ce soit nicolas sarkozy
et manifestement est manifestement ce
soir et partager cet après midi si au
touquet eh bien j'ai un site notre
prochain président de la république
celui qui est aujourd'hui le président
des républicains et j'espère demain le
président notre république à être
beaucoup plus courageux et beaucoup plus
courageux que françois hollande
évidemment ne l'est aujourd'hui
ça va sans dire et demain il faudra
tenir tenir face aux professionnels du
statu quo que sont certains de ses 110
cas qui vivent du financement public
jusqu'à cinq milliards d'euros d'argent
public par an et qui sont là uniquement
pour vous a posé le statu quo et puis
j'en terminerai par là parce qu'on va
évidemment m'expliquer que je suis déjà
trop long c'est vrai que c'est assez
bavard et bien il faudrait être beaucoup
plus courageux aussi sur nos valeurs
assumer ce que nous sommes assumer
d'être de droite assumé d'être patriote
assumer notre histoire assumer nos
racines chrétiennes oui nous sommes un
pays de tradition chrétienne
oui nous refuserons négocier notre mode
de vie
oui nous sommes fiers d'avoir
effectivement interdit dans l'espace
public le port de la burqa non pas parce
que nous opposons à quelques confessions
ce soit mais tout simplement parce que
la république
elle n'est pas à la carte et puis
beaucoup plus courageux dans nos valeurs
il ya une valeur moi qui m'importe
énormément c'est le respect nous sommes
dans une société où on ne respecte plus
rien nous sommes dans une société où on
vient agressé une personne âgée pour lui
voler son sac et lui prendre 10 euros
nous sommes dans une société où le ton
monte au sein des guichets
d'administration pour pas grand chose
nous sommes dans une société où certains
nos concitoyens sont prêts à se battre
pour une place de parking
nous sommes dans une société où notre
mais plus grand chose et effectivement
c'est pas la faute des professeurs parce
que les socialistes ont souvent envoyé
les professeurs les moins expérimentés
dans les quartiers les plus sensibles et
que nos professeurs n'ont pas été
suffisamment valorisé mais j'estime
aujourd'hui que à partir du moment où
nos valeurs ne sont plus transmise à
partir du moment où beaucoup
d'enseignants ont dû démissionner de
leurs missions d'instruction où beaucoup
de parents n'ont plus la possibilité ou
non courage ou l'autorité suffisante
pour s'occuper et maîtriser leurs
enfants et bien j'estime que c'est à
l'état de reprendre le flambeau et moi
je propose à titre personnel que nous
rétablissions le service militaire et
civique obligatoire
je le propose non pas par goût excessif
pour le militarisme mais tout simplement
parce qu'il faut un moment où chacun de
nos concitoyens jeunes garçons et filles
quelles que soient ses confessions
quelles que soient ses origines sociales
apprennent tout simplement à vivre
ensemble à travailler ensemble à se
respecter mutuellement apprendre à
devenir des citoyens
alors mes amis j'en termine je vous dis
juste que face à tous ces défis que face
à tout ce qui nous attend que face au
courage dont nous allons tous devoir
faire preuve jeudi tous pas seulement
ceux qui sont à la tribune pas seulement
nicolas sarkozy que vous écouterez tout
à l'heure mais vous tous aussi pour
reconquérir les territoires et les
coeurs en 2017
nous aurons besoin de l'expérience de
nos aînés nous aurons besoin de
l'expérience hors pair et de l'autorité
de la capacité d'entraînement de la
force de persuasion de nicolas sarkozy
mais nous aurons aussi besoin de la
relève et de tous ces jeunes que vous
êtes venu soutenir aujourd'hui je vous
le dis
ne la cherchez à rien merci